a classic movie about america's pastime
and our interview with its star for
years fans of kevin costner's beloved
1989 baseball film field of dreams have
found their way to dyersville iowa to
see where it was filmed well today that
big screen dream is becoming a big
league reality when the yankees and
white sox face off on a field
constructed right next to the actual
movie set in custom throwback uniforms
we're going to talk to costner in just a
moment but first mola lange tells us
about today's special game mola good
morning to you toss into baseball
confidently on camera live
that's right tony you know how to handle
one of these things i know that now you
might recognize this field behind me
that is where the iconic film
was made some 30 years ago just beyond
the corn stalks in the outfield there
right in the distance you see the field
that major league baseball built for
tonight's game they had to haul in 4 000
tons of sand 2 000 tons of gravel had to
build this thing from scratch now the
stands out there will be filled with
about 8 000 fans tonight many of whom
will be iowans are iowans who will be
seeing not only the first major league
baseball game ever played here in the
state of iowa but they will finally get
to see movie magic on a field of dreams
become a reality
it only took 32 years but major league
baseball has finally come to iowa
inspired by the 1989 movie field of
dreams starring kevin costner as an iowa
farmer who builds a ball field in his
corn field tonight in dyersville iowa
the movie will come to life on a new
field right next to the movie set
there's a manual scoreboard the way the
corn just kind of grows it looks like it
just goes on forever unbelievable
it's more than that
it's perfect in right field there's a
gate where the players will actually
enter the field and they'll come out of
the corn a lot like it was in the movie
the movie so popular among fans it's now
part of baseball lore uses the game to
tell a story about fathers and sons and
repairing the past the idea that
baseball brings together communities it
brings together generations and families
i think is what makes baseball special
when larry bailey heard they were hiring
fans to work the game he and his wife
drove 500 miles from kentucky i'm a
baseball nut the guy is like a kid again
baseball makes you feel like you're 12
whether you're 7 or 70. when i stepped
from the grass onto the dirt i felt
something a little bit magical happen a
big kid
on a ball field in a cornfield
living a dream is this heaven
[Music]
it's iowa